ben je me présente c'est moi votre
chirurgien on
s'ennuie ah salut les petits connard le
DVD numéro 4 de Joueur du Grenier est
sorti et tu sais quoi il y en a
qure alors tu vas l'acheter hein comment
ça tu as pas d'argent et ton frère et
vous pouvez pas la passer celle-là alors
maintenant imaginez-vous 25 ans en AR
hier dans les années 90 quand les spot
de pub dur plusieurs minutes maintenant
avec Internet les pubs tout le monde les
bloque ou les passe c'est devenu
impensable de prendre 30 secondes
entière de la vie de quelqu'un tu le
rends fous ça va et 30 secondes c'est
quoi dans la vie de quelqu'un mê d'un
[Musique]
photo bref vous l'avez compris salut
tout le monde on est reparti pour un
petit hor sujet et encore une fois on va
parler de pub
[Musique]
1 2 3 4
[Applaudissements]
c'est très facile aujourd'hui
d'identifier une période de temps
simplement en regardant les pubs qui
sont à coller suffit de voir si je vous
montre 2 minutes de télé des années 90
vous allez immédiatement le reconnaître
ne serait-ce qu'avevec les pubs de
musique qui sont ultra daté la dance
tout ça mais ça marche également avec
les pubs toutes simples typiquement les
pubs de yop ah la délinquence des années
90 c'était bien quand même ça a l'air
pas mal du tout ce que tu es en train de
te taper là hein eh
ce serait pas un mais bon encore là ça
va à ce momentl les racue vol du yaourt
puis ensuite la fin des années 90 les
voitures commen à
brûler dis donc les mec on fait ça ils
ont vraiment à la place du
cerveau ok alors sérieusement
heureusement que le nom du produit est
mentionné parce que la pub est pas
évidente là je trouve ah là là je suis
complètement perdu sérieusement vous
avez déjà vu des gens boire du Yob dans
la rue par contre banga ça c'était une
vraie boisson et puis la pub est défoncé
en plus défoncé tellement que j'arrête
pas de vous la montrer en fait ce truc
de marcher sur les margelles en
imaginant que le sol était rempli de
lave tout le monde l'a fait par contre
ce pauvre gosse elle aurait l'appeler
autrement maman pourquoi tu m'as appelé
comme ça tout le monde se moque de moi à
l'école tais-toi et va chercher ton
petit frère docteur Pepper oui
d'ailleurs au passage puisquon est au
pub de boisson je vais pas parler du
nombre hallucinant de pub qui te mettait
juste une paire de loge sous le nez pour
te faire acheter de Rio rien ne vaut un
rio eh j'ai vu les melons mais j'ai pas
vu les
oranges maman faut qu'on parle ah maman
faut qu'on parle la pub de petit Vitel
c'est un exemple parfait des pubs qui
sont restés dans la mémoire ils avaient
su parfaitement jouer avec le côté manga
des baisettes gros muscles et cheveux
blonds non parce que le il me faut de
l'eau ça faisait partie des slogans
insupportables que tout le monde te
ressortait à longueur de journée je veux
dire ce que vous avez rêvé de péter les
dents à la 54e personne de la journée à
vous ressortir et la marmotte elle met
le chocolat
dans désolé c'est un réflexe j'ai pas pu
m'en empêcher voà vous voyez maman faut
qu'on parle bon cela dit je me demandais
quand même ce qui arrivait à la fin de
cette pub faut qu'on parle mon corps est
en pleine
croissance il me faut des d'ailleurs les
parents qui se laissaient rouler dessus
c'était un truc assez récurrent à
l'époque je veux dire quoi de mieux pour
parler aux enfants que de montrer qu'ils
peuvent dominer leurs parents rendeznous
le chien on a champom champom
d'abord avec moi serait pas arrivé
ça je négocie pas avec les
terroristes ne CZ pas au terrorisme
battez-vous les jeunes ils sont si durs
à comprendre souvenez-vous la SNCF mais
c'est ble bien maintenant il y a la pub
Oasis comment c'est de la balle tu
m'étonnes que c'est de la balle ah mais
que dit-il je ne comprends pas
heureusement qu'il y ait la traduction
dessous il pensait que les parents ils
allaient réagir comment je ne comprends
pas ce jeune homme vient de dire c'est
trop de la balle alors que bon ce n'est
pas une balle c'est une bouteille ça n'a
aucun
sens d'ailleurs c'est fou comme c'est
vraiment le langage des jeunes mais vu
par les vieux ouais doncou quoi quoi
donc lou quoi alors je m'adresse
maintenant aux gens plus jeunes que moi
parce que bon en 2002 j'avais déjà
atteint le vénérablâge de 22 ans que
signifie le terme don chelouf quoi don
chelouf quoi et également est-ce que
vous utilisiez vraiment le terme c'est
grave ch max en 2002 parce que dans mes
souvenirs c'était déjà ringa en
95 c'est l'heure du BN B les pubs de BN
ça ça me donne faim de à l'école les
batteries sont à plat un autre
ah est-ce que ce gosse a pas des
couilles en acier ah non Satan est
encore dans mon sac reviens je sais où
tu habites et d'ailleurs si vous voulez
briller en soirée BN ça veut dire
biscuit rinanta dans les autres pubs de
trucs à bouffer je me souviens aussi des
pubs de crunch d'ailleurs je me faisais
aussi la réflexion quand j'étais petit
que c'était quand même des pubs de
connard je veux dire le concept est
vieux on mange un crunch ça provoque un
accident
toi c'est un peu comme un
des
notour il respire plus non mais je veux
dire sincèrement
regardez qu'est-ce que ce mec t'a fait
il faisait sa Gy chez lui t'emmerdais
pas tu pouvais juste tourner la tête
alors pourquoi tu détruit sa maison Meur
espèce de sale gros je te tuerai je
tuerai ta famille papa j'ai peur crunch
le chocolat des [ __ ] B après on
rigole on se moque un peu mais bon
quelque part au moins il y avait un
effort de créativité je crois qu'on est
bien
d'accordox tout le monde aime ça Julie
c'est pour ses grands pétales de maïs
tout doré Pierro parce qu'il crus
longtemps et Laurence pour leur bon goût
nature ah la vache mais il y a tellement
rien de naturel dans cette pub CIS qu'on
est bien d'accord je crois qu'on est
bien d'accord non mais sérieusement
c'est trop bizarre on dirait qu'il y a
quelqu'un qui les oblige à
parler moi je les aime parce que c'est
naturel et croquant et ça facilite le
transit intestinal moi Rais j'adore ou
alors par contre niveau contenu de la
pub le département créativité il était
en
vacances quand je bois de la
cristalline j'ai plus soif grâce à mon
assurance quand j'ai un accident des
fois je suis remboursé ça dépend si je
suis en tort ou pas si je dépasse pas la
franchise aussi ça dépend de plein de
[Musique]
trucs je pense que la plupart d'entre
vous ne s'en souvient pas mais il y a
plusieurs marques qui ont tenté de faire
passer leurs produits pour des produits
de luxe alors parfois ça a marché
Ferrero Rocher ça a une image de truc
classe ou le jambon d'OST ou bon ils ont
essayé ça avec les r bord chînel mais ça
c'était plutôt de la parodie mais des
fois ben ça marche
pas est-ce qu'elle est en train de
souffler sur un carton surgelé donc
crusti cha une croquette au fromage
alors je suis admiratif quand même de la
tentative de faire passer pour un truc
de luxe un truc qui s'appelle crustio
avec un haut non parce que c'est mort et
là c'est une croquette panée je veux
dire même la meilleure des pubs ne peut
pas vous transformer ça en truc chic
madame monsieur pour le plat suivant je
vous propose donc un écrain de panure
garni au fromage sur son lit de
printemps accompagné de ketchup ah les
pubs de cahier alors ça c'était la
période que tout le monde détestait en
général ça commençait à apparaître à peu
près mi-août et ça signifie qu'une chose
la rentrée arrive on va regarder une
monsieur désirembala crayon noir nous
parle des cahiers super concurrents
super concurrent il est si agréable pour
écrire et il est robuste oui oui oui
super super con jeahier il est
super comment ça va
[Musique]
bien bien vous savez ce qui va se passer
ensuite comment ça va je vais bien vous
avez bonne m comment ce truc pouvait
être légal pour les plus jeunchez que à
l'époque faire çaér
[Musique]
mercureome le pcement des héros c'était
légal je n'ai pas retouché la vidéo je
n'ai pas rebouclé moi-même le montage
c'était comme ça à la télé et c'est
incroyable c'est littéralement ils ont
trouvé le bug exploit de la pub pour te
faire rentrer un truc dans la tête
attendez on a droit à 30 secondes c'est
ça et on peut mettre ce qu'on veut
n'importe quoi et le pire c'est que ça
marchait ça restait dans la tête ça se
demandait pourquoi tout le monde faisait
pas pareil pousousse ça Fousse sa mousse
pousse mousse çaousse sa mousse pous
mousse çaousse sa mousse Nutella oh tu
es là Nutella oh tu es là
Nutella tu es
là quand les petits frères entrent à pas
de loup tu peux cacher tes trésors dans
un Ker ah ben enfin les pubs de jouet
est-ce que c'est pas le moment qu'on
attendait tous les premières pubs de
jouet qui apparaissaient à la télé ça
signifiait une chose noël arrive et les
vacances arrivent al ça c'était la pub
de Keepers une espèce de boîte à secret
pour filles je m'en souviens parce que
déjà quand j'étais petit garçon je
comprenais pas le principe d'avoir une
boîte à secret quand tu avais 6 ou 7 ans
qu'est-ce que tu avis à cacher après
vers 12 13 ans quand tu commences à être
ADS là je veux bien comprendre l'utilité
d'une boîte à
Secret grâce à Keepers tu peux cacher
tous tes secrets tes pétards ton canif
pour te battre avec des gangs de ru ou
ton test de grossesse positif alors les
pubs de jouet c'est quelque chose qui a
pas mal évolué dans les années 90 pour
le coup on est parti de loin où il est
ton kiki je ne répondrai pas à cette
question kiki c'est le kiki de tous les
kiki ne confiez pas vos enfants à
n'importe qui ou plutôt porte
kiki après dans les années 80 il y avait
une forme d'innocence qui n'existe plus
aujourd'hui c'est sûr que refaire la
même pub maintenant ça serait impossible
alors il est où ton
kiki d'ailleurs tant qu'on est dans les
vieilles pubs est-ce que vous avez déjà
eu ce genre de chos en étant petit je me
souviens parfaitement qu'on était noyé
par les pubs comme ça et que ce soit les
play-do ou la pâte à modeler pour faire
de la fausse nourriture ou des espèces
de chariots qui te permettaient de jouer
à l'épicier ou à n'importe quel autre
métier cont jete au plaond quoi trop
content je monte au
plafond non mais je monte au plafond je
veux dire c'est n'importe quoi on va pas
garder ça évidemment bon ca dit au moins
c'était un jouet neutre parce que les
jouets à l'époque c'était pas pour tout
le monde voilà Monsieur dans son atelier
Berchet super équipé madame n'est pas un
reste avec sa cuisine super Cook four
mais aussi oh ça va les Meur étent
différent dans les années
70 90 70 90 c'est des chiffres tout ça
évidemment inutile de dire que les
vieilles pubs pour gamin é trué de
machine à laver de cuisinière et de
trucs qui même plus à dé jouer en fait
oh le chien et attention on fait que des
bêtises la poussette ménage Smoby et du
coup ça c'est un jouet oui non parce
qu'elle elle a vraiment fait le ménage
là oui alors après ils ont quand même
essayé d'adoucir la pub plus tard en
rajoutant une petite chanson mais c'est
fou ça marche mieux en
fait toute la journée toute cette
poussière je la mets en l'air ben voilà
là c'est un jouet c'est fou comme un
petit air sympa ça rend tout plus
[Musique]
agréablelaration la tax foncire
j déclaration de revenu un jouer bon
après on va pas toutes les faire c pub
on en aurait pour la journée et puis on
va pas engager le débat de est-ce que
c'est bien c'est pas bien on n pas là
pour ça par contre on va quand même
rester dans les jouets pour filles maman
pour moi j'aimerais un bébé une petite
blonde avec des boucle et un petit
n
bébéé ce zoom a duré beaucoup trop
longtemps là rien que la vignette dans
mon navigateur me fait flipper alors je
sais qu'on a déjà abordé les pubes de
poupon dans la dernière vidéo mais il y
en a tellement de ces
[Musique]
merdes lanc [ __ ] ça ça s'appelle
Screamer les mecs je crois vraiment
qu'on aura tout eu pour les bébés ceux
qui chient ceux qui pleurent ceux qui
pissent ceux qui sont malades ceux qui
font les quatre en même temps je suis
sûr que les petites filles ont une
passion pour les flUes corporel mais à
un moment ça devient malsin première
larme poupée de charme au chagrin
délicieux ce n'est qu'un jeu car tu
pleures quand je veux heureusement qu'il
y avait des bébés un peu plus basiques
comme les jouets Luxy c'était des bébés
qui brillent dans la nuit alors par
contre je sais pas du tout pourquoi je
me souviens de la pub quand on sert Luxy
dans ses bras on a plus peur la nuit ah
oui mauvais casting de voix bonah C dit
on a été épargné par la pire des pubs de
jouet c'est une pub pour un bébé qui
s'appelle baby lofelot bébé rigole
beaucoup oui et surtout alors n'oubliez
pas de changer les piles parce qu'en
fait si vous changez pas les piles voilà
ce qui peut se passer au milieu de la
nuit
bah après évidemment je parle des
poupées mais les jouets pour filles ne
se limitaent pas qu'à ça il y avait
aussi les jeux de société pour filles
uniquement alors le téléphone secret
c'est un je électronique
avecé que ces garçons ne sont pas quand
même beaucoup plus vieux qu'elle parce
que c'est sûr là ils mettent des beaux
gosses musclé alors ça donne l'illusion
mais remplace ça par des mecs normaux et
c'est plus la même
[Musique]
allô et après évidemment j'en ai pas
parlé mais il y avait tout le bordel des
jouets Barbie Barbie roller Barbie
cabriolet l'avion de Barbie la merde
comparit un are truc à nous les mecs
Action Man roller extrême Action Man
silver speider Action Man turbo motojet
voilà ça c'est bien Action Man VTT
télécommandéb ça c'est pour les hommes
mer je crois que le son est décalé là
j'ai pas remarqué alors finalement
qu'est-ce qu'on avait juste à nous les
mecs et ben déjà il y avait la catégorie
les jouets immondes une mode passagère
des années 90 avec des jouets
dégueulasses un type creepy crawers g le
savant fou c'est juste des
jouets comment dire de toute façon c'est
simple la pubé dégoûtante ça pue on
dirait un mélange de mort de diarrée
c'est pour les mecs ouais on est sale
alors si à la limite il y avait d'autres
truc il y avait les bagnoles ça c'était
bien à nous et puis il y avait la guerre
nous on aime bien la guerre et la
violence et les dinosaures
et les trucs qui pu alors il y en a qui
ont essayé de combiner tout ça extanimal
c'est des voitures avec des têtes de
dinosaures qui se font la guerre
extanimal achet s'il vous plaît je
regrette un peu qu'on a pas été adulte
dans les années 90 parce qu'on aurait pu
faire fortune en inventant le jouet
ultime tur V du futur du systèmeonen
peupl de cyber dinosaures et est venu
sur notre
planète turosaur il se débarrass de ses
enemis en leur vitant dus
ah dégueulasse met un doigt à l'arrière
de turbocradosaur et il se mettra à
parler c'est ch max j'ai une blénovagie
je vais dissoudre l'Assemblée nationale
yeah
turbocranosaur jou interdit par la
Commission européenne ça déci et ben
toutes ces pubs moi je sais pas pour
vous mais ça m'a donné faim du coup ben
je mangerai bien un petit que dirais-tu
de goûter à mes délicieux bâtonnets de
Colin croustillant et ça vous revoit là
tout l'ORD du captaine et il est pour
vous
c'est c'est c'est un crusti show
[Musique]
oui ma perfection
mascul sur tous les visages tu le
çaand donner d'avantage pour le meilleur
de toi